in a beast they've nicknamed the Dragon
for its size and power this squad of
young soldiers harnesses a gepard to
slay their enemies
drones are not difficult for her at all
Roman were only using his first name
commands the team of three which
includes Alex and alexand they were all
trained on the anti-aircraft system in
Germany the gephard with its twin 35
millimeter cannons was developed in the
60s Germany decommissioned the units
more than a decade ago then last year
the gephards were donated and pressed
into service in defense of Ukraine
the automatic cannons can engage targets
within 6 000 meters protecting people
and critical infrastructure in the
capital region with a high rate of
success
the first Downing we had was a cruise
missile says Alex she flew past us we
captured her and shot her down it was
Winter and of course there was Joy
fact during the month of May Ukrainian
officials say the capital was targeted
on 21 days by Russian aerial attacks air
defense systems have been able to
intercept those incoming drones and
missiles giving residents a bit of Hope
when people hear a drone which sounds
similar to a moped in the sky they pause
listening optimistically for a
successful air defense takedown
it's a feeling a short-term feeling of
inspiration that we are doing the right
job Roman was an engineer before the
full invasion the 28 year old has
learned every inch of his gephard he
walks Global News through where the
links of ammunition are fed down below
the Gunner highlights the onboard radar
and shows us his seat in the turret it's
really hard to get the true
understanding of it but it is an
incredibly small little space it's
expected this Summer that the first
rounds of German produced ammunition
will be sent to Ukraine the gephard can
fire more than 1 000 rounds per minute
earlier this year Germany's defense
minister announced a deal with a local
manufacturer to start producing the
rounds in country again to ensure
Ukraine would have a steady supply of
ammunition Switzerland is debating the
sale of its warm materials to third
parties so Ukraine could benefit
Roman speaks a little English and makes
a clear ask of Canada and all Allied
Nations
protecting their country means
protecting their families Alex used to
be a bartender the 31 year old was known
for his pina coladas now he serves his
country just like his mom and dad were
on the front lines
I worry and they worry we try to call
each other every day if possible
ukrainians are battling on all fronts to
protect their people and secure their
borders countries have donated several
different types of anti-aircraft weapons
to be used around the country including
34 gephards from Germany Roman Alex and
Alexander say they can rely on their
dragon and are ready to release it when
needed
Crystal commencing global news keep
region Ukraine